[Music]
life on earth depends on the Goldilocks
climate not too hot and not too cold
humankind is changing that
industrialization has raised
temperatures around one degree experts
think a further rise of another degree
is possible by 2050 - even after big
emissions cuts crops will be more likely
to fail displacing human populations in
Paris in 2015 industrialized nations
agreed they would limit global warming
to less than two degrees above
pre-industrial eyes levels but there has
been more hot air than action
nations cannot agree how much each
should cut emissions rising populism has
Foster's skepticism about global warming
under Donald Trump
the US has threatened to withdraw from
the Paris Accord they have a collective
action problem everyone would benefit
from cutting emissions eventually no one
wants to be the prime mover so there is
no progress the reason is that the costs
of global warming
remain an externality for most
individuals there is no immediate
benefit in reducing them as a result
except when protestors from extinction
rebellion disrupt the traffic as they
did recently in London it is they
sometimes say in business nnp or next
management's problem by the same logic
as temperatures rise people will start
barring direct costs for example some
populous parts of the world will become
too hot to inhabit in the summer or to
visitors tourists effects such as these
will create nations will start taking
action squabbling will continue one
flashpoint will be output of polluting
coal this is expected to peak well over
eight billion metric tons in 2030 many
in China and India see Western demands
for production cuts as self-serving even
within developed nations that will be
called
Flitz US researchers have predicted
hefty economic damage to Texas and
Florida later this century coupled with
more modest benefits for the states of
Washington Oregon what will the
consequences be for investors the value
of big oil companies such as royal
dutch/shell would fall if reserves
cannot be exploited fully they need to
be discounted heavily the value of
renewables groups like Denmark's earth
debt would go up reflecting a growing
market their technologies would depend
less and less on subsidies to make
profits nuclear generation make a
resurgence as a supplier of baseload
electricity that would bolster the price
of uranium which has been depressed
since the Fukushima disaster extreme
weather would become more common that
would make farming investment riskier
but agricultural commodities trading
more lucrative demand for catastrophe
insurance would continue to rise sharply
bolstering Lloyd's of London in the
market for catastrophe bonds some
competing companies appear more
committed to a low-carbon economy than
competing nations JPMorgan estimates
three fifths of car sales will be
hybrids or fully electric by 2030 that
compares with two percent in 2015 Lexx
believes big traditional car makers such
as VW and GM will succeed in switching
wholesale into electric vehicle output
they understand mass production after
all that will leave Tesla where it is
now as a niche business if it is not
bought out another interesting niche
will be hydrogen fuel cell vehicles
Toyota has made a side bet these will be
needed for hauling heavy loads the
reason
grace in the weight to power ratio of
batteries has been linear exponential
growth would be needed for battery
powered vehicles to become universal
experts say businesses will need to make
a lot of other intelligent bets to build
the low-carbon economy governments will
belatedly impose the incentives and
penalties needed the one certainty of
climate change is that business as usual
will not be an option